สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียน
ภาษาไทยห้องเรียน comprehensive ไทยค่ะ
ค่ะแล้วในวันนี้นะคะครูปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มา
เจอกับทุกๆคนนะคะในวันนี้คือวันอะไรคะครู
ชิวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะครูปุ๊กวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะ 25 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนกันยายนค่ะ
เดือนกันยายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไร่คะเป็น
เดือนที่ 9 ค่ะปีพุทธศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
ปีพุทธศักราช
2566 ค่ะปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะปี
คริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะค่ะนะวันนี้ก็เป็นวันจันทร์วัน
ที่ 25 เดือนกันยายนตรงกับเอ่อเดือนที่ 9
เนาะปีพุทธศักราชหรือว่าพ.ศ
2566 ปีคริสตศักราชหรือค.ศ
2023 ค่ะนะคะ
ค่ะวันนี้วันนี้ครูชิเเนี่ยจะชวนครูปุ๊ก
มาคุยเรื่องอะไรคะครูชิเห็นว่าช่วงเนี้ย
ค่ะช่วงนี้เป็นช่วงที่หน้าฝนประเทศไทย
นะคะแล้วก็มีสัตว์ในทะเลที่คนไปเล่นน้ำ
อ่ะไปเจอแล้วก็โดนพิษเ่ะก็เลยอยากจะเอา
เรื่องเนี้ยมาพูดคุยกับครูปุ๊กค่ะ
อ๋อพิษของสัตว์ใช่มั้ยก็คือสัตว์ที่มันมี
พิษเนี่ยมันกัดน่ะมันก็จะทำให้พิษเนี่ย
เข้าไปที่หัวใจตุบๆๆๆๆๆแล้วก็เราก็จะตาย
อย่างนี้ใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะครูปุ๊กคือบางทีมัน
อาจจะพิษอาจจะไม่ได้แรงถึงขนาดนั้นแต่
จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยบางทีคนที่ไปเอ่อว่ายน้ำ
อ่ะก็มักจะแบบว่าดำน้ำลงไปแล้วก็ชอบไป
สัมผัสอ่ะแล้วก็จับไปจับไป
แตะสิ่งที่อยู่ใต้ทะเลแล้วเราก็ไม่รู้ไง
ว่าอันนั้นเนี่ยมันมีพิษหรือไม่มีพิษใช่
มั้ยคะอืวันนี้เนี่ยเราก็เลยจะเอาเรื่อง
นี้มาคุยกันค่ะครูปุ๊กโอดีเลยค่ะครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยก็ชอบนะคะชอบทะเลแล้วก็ประเทศไทย
เนี่ยก็มีทะเลสวยๆเยอะแล้วก็เหมือนกับว่า
ครูชี้มาบอกเนี่ยนักเรียนเนี่ยก็จะได้รู้
ด้วยเวลามาเที่ยวประเทศไทยถ้านักเรียนไป
เจออะไรที่เป็นสัตว์แล้วก็มันอาจจะมีพิษ
ก็จะได้ระวังเนาะนะใช่ค่ะแล้วมันมีก็พิษ
แรกเนี่ยครููชิคิดว่าเอ่อหลายๆคนเนี่ยคง
จะรู้จักปลาปลาการ์ตูน
อ่าใช่ค่ะปลาการ์ตูนน่ารักน่ารักตัวเล็กๆ
ค่ะครูปุ๊กก็ชอบครูปุ๊กชอบปลาการ์ตูนแต่
แต่อะไรที่มันมีพิษล่ะคะครูชิอันนี้ค่ะ
สิ่งที่ปลาการ์ตูนไปอยู่ก็คือดอกไม้ทะเล
ค่ะเอ้านะเอ้าแล้วดอกไม้ทะเลมีพิษแล้วปลา
การ์ตูนเนี่ยมันไม่ตายเหรอคะครูชิเอ่อปลา
การ์ตูนไม่เป็นไรค่ะเพราะมันมีเมือกก็คือ
มีสารมาเคลือบผิวมันไว้เพราะฉะนั้นอย่าง
แรกอย่างแรกเลยนะคะถ้าเกิดคนที่ดำน้ำไป
แล้วชอบปลาการ์ตูนแล้วก็ก็ไปจับปลา
การ์ตูนเนี่ยอันเนี้ยจะจะอันตรายไม่ใช่
อันตรายกับเรานะคะะอันตรายกับปลาการ์ตูน
ค่ะเพราะว่าพอเราไปจับน่ะเมือกที่มันมัน
เอ่อเคือบปลากตูนอยู่อ่ะเหมือนๆใช่มัน
เหมือนกับเป็นเมือกเมือกเมือกมันคือแบบ
สารที่แบบเหมือนกับเหนียวๆเหมือนแป้ง
เหมือนน้ำแป้งหนืดๆเวลาเราจับแล้วมันจะ
บึ๋งปึ๋งึเงี้ยมันมันลื่นๆลื่นๆใช่มยใช่
มันลื่นๆมันจะเป็นตัวกั้นพิษให้ปลา
การ์ตูนแต่พอเราไปจับปลาการ์ตูนมาเล่นน่ะ
ใช่มั้ยคะเมือกอันนั้นน่ะมันหลุดออกแล้ว
พอเราปล่อยไปปลาการ์ตูนเข้าไปดอกไม้้ทะเล
ปลาการ์ตูนก็โดนดอกไม้ทะเลกินค่ะอ๋อแล้ว
ปลาการ์ตูนเนี่ยมันไม่ทำไม่สร้างเมือก
ใหม่ขึ้นมาหรอคะครูมันต้องใช้เวลาค่ะมัน
ต้องใช้เวลาใช้เวลาในการสร้างไม่ใช่พอ
ปล่อยปุ๊บปึ๊บโอ้โหเหมือนใส่เสื้อไม่ใช่
ค่ะ
อืมันก็เลยเหมือนกับว่าแล้วปลาการ์ตูนเอง
ก็ไม่รู้หรอค่ะว่าเมือกมันหาย
ไปพอโดยธรรมชาติไงคะพอมีคนไปจับเค้าอ่ะ
เค้าเป็นตัวที่จะล่อล่อปลาล่ออะไรเข้าดอก
ไม้ทะเลอยู่แล้วไงเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
ออโตเมติกค่ะพอโดนปล่อยปุ๊บเค้าก็วิ่ง
เข้าหาดอกไม้ทะเลเหมือนเป็นที่ป้องกันภัย
เอ่ะแต่ปรากฏว่าเค้าก็จะโดนพิษของดอกไม้
ทะเลปลาก็จะเหมือนกับเป็นอัมพาตอ่ะก็คือ
แบบนิ่งเหมือนๆถูกฉีดยาชาขยับไม่ได้
อ๋อเหมือนเหมือนเราเป็นสตกงี้มยมันจะ
แบบเหมันกล้ามเนื้อเราเราแบบขยับไม่ได้
เลยอ่ะค่ะครูกุ๊ออปลาการ์ตูนก็จะโดนดอก
ไม้ทะเลกินอย่างงี้ใช่มยใช่ค่ะโหนะสงสาร
จังเลยตัวอน่ารักแต่พิค่ะแต่พิษเเลกับ
คน่ะบางทีคนก็เห็นอุ๊ยสวยแล้วก็แบบเอาไป
จับอืทีนี้มันขึ้นอยู่กับแต่ละคนแต่ละคน
นะคะว่าคนๆนั้นเนี่ยมีภูมิต้านทานเหมือน
เหมือนเป็นโควิดแล้วมีฉีดวัคซีนวัคซีนมี
ภูมิต้านทานใช่มั้ย
อ่าไม่ให้ไม่ให้เอ่อเชื้อโรคเข้ามาในร่าง
กายเราอันนี้ก็เหมือนกันถ้าเกิดครูชิ
เนี่ยมีภูมิต้านทานเวลาโดนดอกไม้ทะเลูชิ
จะแบบแค่คันๆแแคคันๆเจ็บๆแต่คนที่แพ้
เนี่ยมันจะเหมือนโดนน้ำร้อนลวกค่ะครูปุ๊ก
ว้าวมันจะปวดแสบปวดร้อนสำหรับคนที่แบบแพ้
นะคะเนี่ยค่ะอืเป็นตุ่มเหมือนแบบโดนน้ำ
ร้อนน่ะอันนี้คือตุ่มของดอกไม้ทะเลแต่ละ
แต่ละดอกอ่ะเข็มเข็มพิษเค้าตำมาที่ตัวของ
คนที่ไปจับอ่ะอืมนะอันนี้ก็แล้วมันก็จะ
แบบโอๆโอเคครูชิเอ่อจริงๆมันมีภาพอีกภาพ
นึงที่ให้เห็นว่าเอ่อเวลาโดนแล้วเนี่ยมัน
จะแบบเหมือนกับบางคนไหม้เลยค่ะเป็นรอย
ไหม้เหมือนโดนน้ำร้อนลวกแรงๆไหม้ครูปุ๊ก
คิดว่าคนเนี้ยเขาต้องไปจับปลาการ์ตูนแน่ๆ
เลยเพราะว่ามันถึงได้โดนทางนี้ไงปกติเรา
จะจับแบบนี้ใช่มยแต่ถ้าเราไปแบบ
เนี้ยมือเข้าไปจะช้อนเออช้อนปลาการ์ตูน
เพราะว่าปลาการ์ตูนเขาจะแหวกว่าอยู่ในดอก
ไม้ทะเลเนาะจริงๆสวยมากนะไม่อย่าไปจับนะ
คะปาการ์ตูนเนี่ยนะสงสารเค้าถ้าเกิดเราทำ
ให้เมือกเค้าหลุดเนี่ยนะเขาก็จะไม่มีอะไร
สำหรับป้องกันตัวเองเนาะแล้วก็ดอกไม้ทะเล
เนี่ยมันมีพิษแล้วพิษมันอยู่ตรงไหนอ่ะคะ
ูชิพิษมันอยู่ตรง
เอ่อตรงปลายของดอกไม้ทะเลอ่ะค่ะออที่เรา
เห็นเป็นตุ่มๆนะคะตรงนี้ค่ะพิษเ้าอยู่ตรง
นี้นี่
ค่ะอ๋อตรงปลายของเส้นเลยใช่มั้ยมันเป็น
อ๋อใชค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยผู้หญิงคนที่โดน
น่ะก็เลยมีเหมือนกับเป็นโดนพิษแบบเป็นจุด
ๆจุๆเต็มมือเหมือนกับโดนน้ำร้อนหยดตึ๊กๆๆ
แล้วมันก็พองเป็นน้ำเสร็จแล้วพอน้ำแตกมัน
ก็เหมือนกับเป็นรอยไหม้บางคนแพ้ก็เหมือน
โดนคือคนที่ไม่แพ้เนี่ยก็จะไม่เป็นอะไร
มากค่ะครูกุ๊กอคนที่แพ้ก็จะเยอะหน่อยอใช่
มยอาจจะแค่คันๆอืใช่อ่ะูชิก็เวลาโดนเนี่ย
มันจะเหมือนกับโดนโดนมีเข็มพิษยิงเข้าไป
อ่ะตึ๊ดๆๆๆแต่พอแบบพอสักพักเนี่ยเราแต่
เราก็ไม่ไปไปกระตุ้นมันน่ะการถูการทำอะไร
มันไปกระตุ้นกระตุ้นทำให้แบบพิษมันมันมัน
ทำงานเพราะฉะนั้นก็แบบเราจะไม่ไปถูไม่ไป
อะไรพอเวลาโดนก็ตึ๊ดๆๆสักพักเราก็แบบโอเค
อ๋อคุชี้ไม่เป็นอะไรอืไม่แพ้เวลาดเวลาโดน
ไม่ว่าจะเป็นพิษเอ่อดอกไม้ทะเลใช่มั้ยูชิ
บอกว่าห้าม
ถูใช่มั้ยเวลาโดนดอกไม้ทะเลเนี่ยนักเรียน
ก็เอามือเนี่ยแกว่งน้ำใช่มั้ยให้น้ำเนี่ย
เป็นตัวพัดเอาออกไปใช่มยแล้วก็จะได้แบบ
ไม่ต้องไม่อย่างงั้นเดี๋ยวไปกระตุ้น
กระตุ้นก็คือทำให้มันรู้สึกต้องทำงานน่ะ
มันต้องทำงานใช่มั้ยเข็มพิษมันก็จะแบบอาจ
จะแตกหรือว่าจะจิ้มลงไปในเนื้อเราอย่าง
งี้ป่ะนะมันก็จะเกิดการแพ้
อ๋อแต่แต่พิษดอกไม้ทะเลเนี่ยมันไม่รุนแรง
ถึงขนาดทำให้เสียชีวิตไงอ๋อไม่ทำให้ตาย
เนาะมันไม่มันไม่ร้ายแรงมากนะก็เหมือนกับ
โดนน้ำร้อนลวกโดนไฟไหม้อย่างเงี้ยน้ำร้อน
ลวกไฟไหม้ก็จะแบบบางคนเป็นเป็นรอยไหม้สี
น้ำตาลบางคนก็แค่พองๆมีน้ำออกมา
อืก็แล้วแต่คนนะคะแต่พิษที่มากกว่านั้นก็
คือปะการังค่ะแล้วที่อันตรายมากเพราะว่า
ปะการังไฟหรือปะการังเอ่อครูชิให้ดู
ปะกาลังนี้ปะการังนี้เนี่ยมีมากในแนวเอ่อ
การดำน้ำของประเทศไทยด้วยเดี๋ยวๆๆูชิคะ
ค่ะ
ปะการังอันนี้ก็มีพิษเหรอคะใช่ค่ะ
ปะการังอันเนี้ยเอ่อสังเกตเอ่อครูปุ๊กจะ
เห็นว่ามันแบบมีเรียบๆอืนะแล้วก็ตรงปลาย
เนี่ยมันจะมีสีใหม่ๆสีใหม่ก็คือแบบตัวตัว
มันสร้างขึ้นมาใหม่นะฮะปะการังตัวเมันมี
พิษเพราะมันมีเข็มพิษอยู่ในตัวนะคะบริเวณ
เนี้ยจะมีเยอะเห็นมั้ยคะแถวๆประเทศไทยเลย
ถ้าคูกุเห็นนี่โอใช่ๆโอมีเยอะมากที่สุด
เอเชียเลยนะใช่ค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเวลาดำ
น้ำเนี่ยลักษณะมันคล้ายๆกันไงมันก็มีมัน
มันมีเข็มแบบเนี้ยพอเวลาโดนมันน่ะเข็มมัน
จะแบบตำเราออันนี้เขาคขยายให้เห็นนะแต่
เวลาที่เราแทบมองไม่เห็นเหมือนเป็นขนน่ะ
ขนเล็กๆบางๆอย่างงี้ใช่มั้ยใช่ใช่ค่ะ
อันเนี้ยโดนแบบเอ่อจะทำให้เกิดแบบรอยไหม้
แบบรุนแรงนะคะแล้วก็จะค่อนข้างเยอะถ้าโดน
ปะการังไฟโอนะนัเป็นลักษณะแบบนี้เลย
ค่ะโหน่ากลัวเนาะครูชิเพราะว่าจริงๆแล้ว
อ่ะครูปุ๊กเห็นมีมีปะการังเนี่ยเยอะๆค่ะ
หลายๆแบบแต่อันเนี้ยชื่อปะการังไฟหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะปากการังไฟนะสีมันจะแดงมั้ยไม่ๆค่ะ
มันไม่แดงแต่ให้สังเกตว่ามันมองแล้วเนี่ย
มันเหมือนกับปะการังมันจะผิวเรียบๆอแต่
ถ้าปะการังตัวอื่นๆเนี่ยมันจะเหมือนกับมี
มีรูของปะการังอ่ะในกิ่งนึงใช่่มั้ยมันจะ
มีตัวปะการังมันจะมีแบบเอ่อมีมีเหมือนกับ
ว่ามันนูนออกมามันไม่เรียบไงอืแต่
อันเนี้ยปะการังไฟเนี่ยมันเหมือนกับเรียบ
แล้วมันก็จะมีเหมือนกับเข็มอ่ะอืมันจะ
เรียบๆแบบนี้นะเรียบๆใช่มั้ยใช่อ๋อแต่ถ้า
เป็นปะการังที่ไม่มีพิษมันก็จะเป็นเหมือน
เป็นจุดๆๆๆๆๆๆอืเป็นรูคล้ายๆพวกหินปูน
หรือว่าเหมือนเหมือนปูนซีเมนต์อย่างงี้
ใช่มยนะมันมีตัวปการ
ทำให้แบบนูนออกมาออออย่างั้นนักเรียนนะคะ
ถ้ามาดำน้ำในประเทศไทยหรือว่าที่ไหนก็ตาม
ให้สังเกตดีๆถ้าปะการังเนี่ยปะการังเนี่ย
มันมีหลายชนิดเนาะแต่อันเนี้ยเป็น
ปะการังไฟนะอันตรายเหมือนกันสำหรับคนที่
แพ้ก็อาจจะแบบไม่สบายได้นะครูชิครูุคิด
ว่าก็เป็นไข้ 2-3 วันค่ะจับคใช่แล้วก็แผล
มันจะเป็นแผลเป็นมันจะเหมือนกับเป็นรอย
ไหม้เาก็เลยเรียกปากการังไฟอจับไข้ก็คือ
ตัวร้อนนะอุณหภูมิเนี่ยจะร้อนมากขึ้นจาก
37 องศเซลเซียเนี่ยก็อาจจะเป็น 38 องศา
39 องศเซซเนาะนะก็คือเราก็บอกว่าเป็นไข้
หรือบางคนเนี่ยภาษาพูดเขาก็จะบอกว่าจับ
ไข้อจับไข้นพอจับดูโอ้โหตัวร้อนนะฮต้อง
นอนอะไรแบบเนี้ยนะคะอันนี้สำหรับคนที่แพ้
นะแต่ก็ยังไม่ได้แบบรุนแรงถึงขนาดเสีย
ชีวิตนะแต่แผลที่โดนน่ะลักษณะเหมือนแมง
กะพรุนน่ะมันจะเป็นแผลเป็นแล้วก็ไหม้แสดง
ว่าแผลอันเนี้ยมันจะไม่หายเลยใช่มยมันจะ
เป็นแบบนี้ตลอดไปแต่อาจจะสีมันอาจจะจางลง
น้อยลงนะแล้วก็อาจจะเป็นคื่นโอ้โหถ้าเกิด
ใครไปโดนที่ตำแหน่งแบบที่มองเห็นชัดๆก็
อันนี้ก็เนาะมันก็ทำให้ไม่สวยได้นะอื
อือหือใช่ค่ะอีกอันนึงนะคะก็จะเป็นเอ่อ
อันเนี้ยอาจจะไม่ได้แบบเป็นมีพิษนะคะแต่
มันอันตรายมากๆเพราะว่าเวลาที่เราไปว่าย
น้ำดำน้ำเนี่ยมันจะชอบติดที่เรือเราอ่ะอุ
เราเรียกว่าหอยเพียง
เนี่ยอ๋อนะอันเนี้ยมันคมมากค่ะครูปุ๊ก
โอ้โหครูปุ๊กเคยมีประสบการณ์ค่ะครูชิ
เพราะว่าน้ำที่มันไหลแรงๆแรงๆใช่มั้ยแล้ว
ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยไปจับเป็นเสาใช่มั้ยเสาเนี่ย
แล้วครูปุ๊กก็ไปจับปึ๊บ
โอ้โหบาดเลยค่ะเหมือนมีดเลยนะแล้วแบบจับ
เนี่ยเพราะว่าน้ำแรงไงเราก็ต้องจับไว้
แน่นๆพอจับแน่นๆเนี่ยมันบาดมืออันเนี้ย
มันยังดีมากค่ะอันเนี้ยยังไม่ค่อยเท่า
ไหร่แต่ถ้ามันแตกเนี่ยมันแตกเนี่ยมันจะ
แหลมมากดูชิมันคมครูปุ๊กมันคมเหมือนมีด
เลยเหมือนมีดแล้วโอ้โหเราอยู่ในน้ำใช่มย
อยู่ในน้ำนานๆเนี่ยเนื้อเราเนี่ยมันจะมัน
จะเปื่อยเปื่อยก็หมายถึงแบบว่าพอโดนนิด
แบบมันก็
แบบไปเลยผมเหมือนกับแช่น้ำอ่ะเนาะแช่น้ำ
เนี่ยมันจะเหมือนกับอ่านให้นักเรียนคิด
ถึงทิชชู่ค่ะทิชชู่เวลาโดนน้ำเนี่ยมันจะ
เปื่อยมันจะค่อยๆยุ่ยออกอืครูชิบอกว่ามือ
เนี่ยเวลาโดนน้ำนานๆเพราะเราเวลาเล่นน้ำ
เราก็ไม่เล่นแค่ 10 นาทีเนาะเราก็เล่นนาน
ๆบางคนเนี่ยเป็นชั่วโมงเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
มือเราเนี่ยจะเป็นเค้าเรียกว่ามันเหี่ยว
เนาะเหมือนสีขาเอนิ่มๆแบบเหมือนจะลอกออก
ได้อ่ะมันยุ่ยอันนี้จะค่อนข้างแบบอันตราย
เหมือนกับคุณจะได้รับบาดเจ็บง่ายเพราะ
อะไรเพราะเวลาคุณไปว่ายน้ำดำน้ำคุณต้อง
ขึ้นเรือลงเรือขึ้นเรือลงเรือให้สังเกต
หรือเวลาที่คุณจะไปจับที่โขดหินที่มีหอย
เพียงพวกเนี้ยต้องระวังมากเหมือนโดนมีด
บาบคมมากแล้วแล้วเวลาเราอยู่ในน้ำอ่ะครู
ปุ๊กเราจะเสียเลือดเยอะคือเลือดมันจะออก
มาแบบเยอะมากอืมันจะไม่หยุดเนาะออแล้วก็
ตอนปีนเรือเนาะบางทีอ่ะบางคนใช้เท้า
ไงใช้เท้าไปยันเรือเอาไว้บางทีมันขวนขา
ได้นะเอ้ยแล้วมันแผลเนี่ยแผลจะไม่สวย
เหมือนมีดบาตรนะเพราะว่าอมันไม่ได้มันคม
ก็จริงแต่มันเหมือนเป็นหยักๆอ่ะบางทีเรา
อาจจะโดนขูดแบบเนื้อมันอาจจะแบบเบอะอ่ะ
ไม่ครูก็เคยแล้วเจ็บมากอืนะคะอือันตราย
อีกอันนึงในช่วงหน้าฝนนะคะประเทศไทยเนี่ย
จะมีเยอะใช่มยก็คือแบบเอ่อตัวนี้ค่ะครู
ปุ๊กเห็นก็อาจจะหนาวนิด
หน่อยโอ้
โหอันนี้เนี่ยแมงใช่่แมงกะพุนไฟเลยล่ะแต่
ประเทศไทยมีหรอคะคุูชิ
ประเทศไทยมีค่ะคือแมงกะพรุนทั้งหลายเนี่ย
มันมีพิษตรงนี้ค่ะครูปุ๊กเนี่ยไหนคะระยาง
ของมันเนี่ยหรือเราเรียกว่าหนวดก็ได้ค่ะ
เนี่ยเหมือนคนมีหนวดแต่แมงกะพุนเนี่ยมี
หนวด
อืโคือถ้าถ้าเราจับตรงเนี้ยไม่มีปัญหาค่ะ
ไม่มีพิษอืนะแต่ถ้าโดนตรงสายมันเนี่ยค่ะ
มีพิษแน่ๆใช่ๆเพราะว่าเวลาเราว่ายน้ำอ่ะ
นะว่ายน้ำเนี่ยบางทีไปพาดพึบูพุกเห็นคน
ที่โดนน่ะบางทีโดนแบบเป็นเส้นๆแบบพาดที่
แขน
อืถ้าถ้าถ้าเราเห็นน่ะเอ่อคนที่โดนพิษแมง
กะพรุนน่ะบางทีเราไม่รู้นะมีเรือวิ่งแล้ว
เรือก็ตัดตรงเนี้ยตัดตัดหนวดอ่ะออกเป็น
เส้นเล็กๆลอยอยู่ในน้ำอ่ะเราไม่รู้เลยว่า
ว่ามีเยอะมากแค่ไหนนะเราอาจจะโดนเข้าไป
ตลอดนะแล้วคนที่โดนเนี่ยก็จะอาการหนักมาก
เนี่ยค่ะเป็นรอยไหม้แบบนี้คือมันถึงมัน
ไม่มีตัวอยู่เนี่ยมันมันก็ยังมีพิษหรอคะ
ูชิ
ใช่ค่ะยังมีพิษอยู่เพราะว่าเข็มพิษของมัน
เนี่ยอยู่ที่หนวดค่ะครูปุ๊กอืเพราะฉะนั้น
บางทีเนี่ยที่เราว่ายน้ำว่ายน้ำแล้วเรา
แบบสะดุ้งปึ๊บอะไรอ่ะนะเพราะว่าเราเจอเจอ
หนวดของมันน่ะเจอหนวดของแมงกะพรุนนะคะครู
ชิจะให้ดูเข็มพิษของแมงกะพรุนค่ะนี่
ค่ะอันนี้
คือหนวดของมันค่ะ
ออแต่หนวดนึงเนี่ยมันไม่ได้มีกระเปาะพิษ
มันไม่ได้มีกระเปาะพิษแค่ 1 ครูปุ๊กเห็น
เข็มพิษที่ออกมามั้ยคะอือหือเข็มพิษที่
ออกมาเป็นเป็นร้อยค่ะโอโหนะแต่ถ้าอือหือ
เป็นเป็น
พันแต่ถ้าเกิดแบบอย่างเงี้ยเราไม่ไปโดน
มันน่ะมันก็จะแบบไม่เอ่อเข็มมันจะไม่โผล่
ออก
มาเข้าใจมั้ยถ้าเกิดเราไปโดนมันปึ๊บเข็ม
มันจะโผล่ออกมาแบบนี้เลยแบบที่ครูปุ๊ก
เห็นนี่
เดี๋ยวนะต้องไปโดนมันมันถึงจะขึ้นมาหรอคะ
ถูกต้องค่ะอ๋อถูกต้องเพราะฉะนั้นถ้าเรา
ไม่โดนมันเราก็ไม่โดนพิษแน่นอนนะคะก็คือ
คุจิจะให้ดูอมันมันลอยอยู่ในน้ำเนี่ยถ้า
ใครไม่ไปโดนมันเนี่ยเข็มพิษมันก็จะไม่ออก
มาอย่างงี้ใช่มยใช่ค่ะมันจะไม่ทำงานอย่าง
ภาพที่ครูปุ๊กเห็นเนี่ยอันนี้เป็นกระเปาะ
พิษของแมงกะพุนที่อยู่ในหนวดสีฟ้าๆนี่คือ
หนวดมันเห็นมอืบางกระเปาะพิษก็ไม่ทำงาน
ค่ะแต่บางกระเปาะพิษก็ทำงานเห็นมยแล้วก็
มันก็จะยิงยิงเข็มอ่ะเข้ามาในร่างกายเรา
แล้วข้างในตัวกระเปาะพิษเนี่ยมันมีมันมี
พิษอยู่เนี่ยมันปล่อยพิษเข้ามาอยู่ในร่าง
กายเราเลยค่ะ
อโอคือที่ครูชิบอกว่าว่าห้ามไปถูเพราะว่า
เดี๋ยวกระเพาะพิษมันเนี่ยจะแตกใช่มยเพราะ
ว่ามันก็จะปล่อยเข็มพิษเข้าไปในร่างกาย
เราเสร็จแล้วมันก็จะปล่อยน้ำพิษเข้าไปทำ
ให้ร่างกายเราอ่ะแบบโอโหน่าจะแบบปวดแสบ
ปวดร้อนนะใช่เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเวลาที่เรา
โดนแมงกะพรุนพลาดมาเส้นนึงอย่างเงี้ยนะคะ
คุณคิดดูเถอะว่าไอ้เส้นเนี้ยมันอาจจะมี
มันอาจจะมีอยู่ 100 กระเปาะสมมุติ 100
มันอาจจะทำงานแค่
50% อีก 5 อาจจะยังไม่ทำงานแต่ถ้าคุณ
เริ่ม
เกาเริ่มถู 100% ค่ะพิษเข้ามา 100% เห็นม
แล้วก็แตกหมดทุกอันด้วยใช่มยใช่
ค่ะอืก็ทำให้เอ่อเราเนี่ยก็จะได้รับพิษมา
โอ้ครูบุ๊กก็เลยได้ยินว่าคนที่โดนเนี่ย
แมงกะพรุนไฟเนี่ยนะก็จะเป็นแบบเป็นแบบพิษ
แมงกะพรุนแมงกะพรุนไฟเนี่ยมันก็จะทำให้
เหมือนโดนไฟไหม้อ่ะค่ะใช่มั้ยูชิแล้วเรา
แล้วอื้อหือก็จะรู้สึกว่าปวดแสบปวดร้อน
เหมือนโดนไฟเา้าก็เลยเรียกว่าแมงกระพรุน
ไฟใช่มั้ยออืใช่ค่ะก็มันมันเอ่อเราเนี่ย
ไม่รู้ว่าอือแมงกะพรุนที่เราโดนเนี่ยมัน
จะเป็นพันธุ์ไหนพิษมันจะแรงหรือไม่แรงแต่
ที่แน่
ๆเราสังเกตว่าถ้าหนวดยิ่งยาวพิษมันก็ต้อง
ยิ่งเยอะถูกมั้ยแล้วไอ้หนวดเส้นนึงอ่ะพิษ
มันมีรอบเข้าใจมั้ยคะรอบที่เนี่ยรอบออบ
หนวดน่ะโอโหใช่มั้ยมันไม่ใช่ไม่ไม่เหมือน
ปลาหมึกเนาะมันจะมีตัวดุดูๆอยู่ฝั่งเดียว
นะอีก 50% ไม่มีแต่อันนี้มีทั้งหมดเลยหรอ
คะครูชิใช่ค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยขึ้นอยู่
กับว่าเราไปโดนตรงจุดไหนครูปุ๊กดูโดนตรง
นี้ก็เข็มออกมาหมดเลยเห็นมั้ยแล้วเข็ม
เหล่าเนี้ยที่โดนโดนเนี่ยนะคะอันนี้คือ
ที่ถ้าถ้าเกิดเข็มที่ออกมาแบบนี้คือพ่น
พิษหมดเลยอือฮึเห็นมพ่นพิษออกมาหมดเลย
ด้านนี้ยังไม่พ่นยังไม่โดนนะอันนี้ยิงพิษ
ใส่เรียบร้อย
นะ
โอ้โหทีเนี้ยถ้าเกิดเอ่อเราโดนพิษแมง
กะพรุนน่ะทีู่ชิบอกอย่างแรกเลยใช่มั้ยคะ
ว่าเราไม่ควรที่จะไปลูหรือเกาหรือค่ะ
อ่ารีบขึ้นจากน้ำค่ะห้ามเกาห้ามหมถูใช่อ
โอ้ยครุูชี่คะครูปุ๊กเคยได้ยินหรอว่าคน
เห็นคนที่เขาทำก็คือเขาจะเอาทรายค่ะเอา
ทรายมาแล้วก็ถูโอ้โหอันนั้นอันตรายมากนะ
คุณรู้ว่าทรายเนี่ยทรายมันมีความคมการถู
เนี่ยมันยิ่งเปิดแผลให้มันใหญ่ขึ้นค่ะ
แล้วทรายเนี่ยไม่รู้ว่ามันมีแบคทีเรียมาก
แค่ไหนถูกมั้ยบางคนก็กินอาหารแล้วก็ทิ้ง
ไปมีสัตว์ที่ตายเป็นแบคทีเรียอยู่ในทราย
แล้วเอาทรายมาถูไม่รู้ว่าคิดได้ยังไงนะคะ
ทีเนี้ยถ้าเกิดว่าคุณโดนน่ะแน่นอนว่าคุณ
ไม่ควรจะไปกระตุ้นให้พิษที่ยังไม่ไม่ยิง
คุณน่ะพิษที่ยังไม่ทำงานเนี่ยทำงานคุณรีบ
ขึขึ้นมาจากน้ำเลยค่ะแล้วก็เอาน้ำเนี่ย
ราดให้ไอหนวดต่างๆเนี่ยให้มันหลุดออกไป
หนวดแมงกะพรุนเนี่ยหลุดอืเสร็จแล้วเนี่ย
ให้หาน้ำส้มสายชู
อ่าให้หาน้ำส้มใส่ชูที่เรากินก๋วยเตี๋ยว
มีน้ำส้มใายชูอ่ะ
อาฮะขอแนะนำว่าต้องเป็นยี่ห้อนี้ค่ะออ
ต้องยี่ห้อนี้ด้วยคือยี่ห้อนี้มีปริมาณ
น้ำส้มสายชูเยอะนะจำโลโก้เอาไว้ตัวที่จะ
ล้างพิษใช่มยใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าอะไรเพราะว่า
เวลาพิษที่เข้าไปในร่างกายเราอ่ะมากๆมัน
เป็นพิษ
โปรตีนพิษโปรตีนเนี่ยมันต้องใช้
กรดมันต้องใช้กรดในการสลายทีเนี้กรดที่
ผิวเราหรับได้มันก็คือน้ำส้มอืน้ำส้มมัน
มีความเป็นกดใช่มั้ยต้องอธิบายว่ามีความ
เป็นมันมีความเปรี้ยวมันกัดอือคือถ้าพเ
เค้าบอกว่าถ้าตรงกลางมันก็จะเป็น 7 ใช่ม
ถ้ากรดมากๆมันก็จะเป็นไปทาง 1 นะแต่ถ้า
เป็นนาก็จะเป็นแบบเอ่อไปนู่นเลยค่ะ 890
ปาเอออ่านะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราอ่ะต้องใช้
น้ำส้มสายชูนะไม่ใช่น้ำส้มที่เราดื่มใช่
มยไม่ใช่ค่ะแล้วยี่ห้อเนี้ยเป็นยี่ห้อที่
มีปริมาณของกดเยอะที่สุดในบรรดาน้ำส้ม
ต่างๆแล้วผิดผิวหนังเรารับได้เราก็จะเอา
น้ำส้มสายชูนนั้นนมาราดค่ะราดลงไปเพื่อ
ให้มันไปทำลายพิษของเอ่อแมงกะพรุนเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะมันก็จะมีตัวที่มีพิษอยู่ที่เนี่ย
ให้ละคือมันบางอันน่ะเราเอามันออกแล้วแต่
มีกระปอกพิษอยู่มีมีเข็มอยู่อ่ะเข้าใจมั้
มีเข็มอยู่เราก็ไปเอาน้ำส้มเนี่ยราดสลาย
ไอ้เข็มตรงนั้นออกไปนะคะแต่พิษที่อยู่ใน
ร่างกายเราเนี่ยต้องมีวิธีอีกค่ะนะออก็
คือครูชิบอกว่าอันดับที่ 1 ก็คือเอาน้ำ
ล้างใช่มั้ยเอาน้ำราดไปเลยนะครั้งที่ 1
เนาะเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยหาน้ำส้มใส่ชูไปที่
ร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวเลยค่ะไปขอเขาหรือไม่ไป
เอ่อเอ่อพวกร้านที่ขายของชำเนาะอย่าง
เซเว่นก็ได้แล้วก็ไปซื้อมาแล้วก็เอามาราด
ราดลงไปนะเพื่อไปสลายพิษเสร็จแล้วเนี่ย
บางบางกระเปาะพิษเนี่ยมันทำงานไปแล้วอก็
ต้องมีมีพิษอยู่ในมีพิษอยู่ในตัวเราแล้ว
นะคะะเต้องบอกว่าพิษของพิษอย่างอย่างที่
ครูชีบอกพิษของ
เอ่อทะเลอ่ะสัตว์ทะเล 90% มันเป็นสัตว์ไง
เพราะฉะนั้นพิษมันก็จะเป็นพิษโปรตีนใช่
มั้ยเพราะฉะนั้นความร้อนมันสลายโปรตีนได้
เพราะฉะนั้นเราต้องไปแช่แช่แขนหรือแช่ตัว
ที่เราโดนแมงกะพรุนน่ะในน้ำน้ำร้อนน่ะไม่
ใช่น้ำร้อนจีนะน้ำน้ำที่เราร่างกายเราทน
ได้เช่นแบบไปแช่อะไรจากุซี่น้ำแบบสัก
ประมาณ 38 องศาถ้าทนได้ถึง 40 ก็เอา 40
บางคนทนได้ถึง 41  42 ก็เอาไปนะเพื่อให้
มันสลายพิษข้างข้างในนะแช่น้ำแช่น้ำอุ่น
แช่น้ำอุ่นไปเรื่อยๆก็ถ้าใครนอนโรงแรม
เนาะก็ไปเปิดน้ำน้ำร้อนที่นักเรียนทนได้
อ่ะเนาะก็ประมาณซักบางคนอาจแบบถ้าเราไม่
ลงไปแช่ทั้งตัวแค่แขนน่ะ 40 องศบางทีอาจ
จะได้ถ้าไม่ได้ก็ลดลงมา 38  36 เอ่อแล้ว
แต่เนาะก็แช่ลงไปให้ความร้อนเนี่ยมันไป
ช่วยสลายโปรตีนของพิษใช่มั้ย
อออันนี้คือเทคนิคใช่มั้ยโอ้โหหลอันนี้
เป็นวิธีที่เราแบบรักษาพิษทางทะเลคือง่าย
ๆถ้าเกิดคุณโดนพิษทางทะเลอ่ะจะเล็กจะน้อย
จะอะไรก็แล้วแต่อย่างแรกเลยคุณไปแช่น้ำ
อุ่นแช่น้ำอุ่นที่คุณทนได้ไปแช่จากุซี่ไป
แช่อะไรเลยอ๋อถ้าเป็นครูปุ๊กนะอย่างงั้น
เนี่ยครูปุ๊กก็จะไปเข้ากลับไปที่โรงแรม
ใช่มั้ยสมมุติโดนที่แขนเนี่ยก็เปิดน้ำที่
น้ำอุ่นเนาะอื้อหือราดลงไปก่อนเลยล้างนะ
จากนั้นเนี่ยก็เอาเอ่ออะไรอ่ะน้ำอุ่น
เนี่ยนะแช่แช่เสร็จแล้วก็น้ำส้มใส่ชูได้
มยน้ำส้มใส่ชูเเนี่ยมันมันล้างพิษอยู่
แล้วไงมันล้างพิษไปแล้วนะคกูปุ๊กแต่เรา
หมดเวลาแล้วสิแบบเราเราไม่
เอ่อคุยได้นิดหน่อยนะโไม่เป็นไรค่ะเดี๋ยว
เรามาคุยกันต่อค่ะเพราะว่าพิษในทางทะเล
เนี่ยมันมีสัตว์ที่มีพิษที่น่าสนใจนะแล้ว
ก็เป็นประโยชน์กับนักเรียนเวลานักเรียนมา
ท่องเที่ยวก็นักเรียนก็จะได้รู้วิธี
ปฏิบัติตัวเองเวลาเราเราโดนพิษนะคะเดี๋ยว
คราวหน้าเรามาคุยกันใหม่ก็ได้ค่ะครูชิยัง
มีอื่นๆอีกใช่มั้ยนะมีค่ะมีพี่เยอะค่ะใน
ทะเลต้องระวังถ้าอย่างงั้นเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอ
กันคลิปต่อไปค่ะขอบคุณค่ะครูชิสวัสดี
ขอบคุณค่ะครูสวัสดีสวัสดีค่ะทุกคนบ๊าย
บาย